ladies with us in Tucson Arizona hi
Brady how are you hey I'm well thank you
so much for taking my call so how can I
help
well I'm in a really sticky situation I
would just like to get your advice on
where to go from here I had a really
successful business that I had built up
for seven years that went sideways on me
but at the beginning of this year since
then I've changed careers and I've been
trying to build up a career as a life
insurance agent over the last six months
ish and what every month it's been hard
to kick off so every month I've been
just caught it's been a really expensive
and you know thing to go through but
it's been kind of you know stand
hopefully been something that was going
to give me something in the future and
then so but I've been steadily going
further and further into death and kind
of once once it got to the point this
last month where the credit cards were
almost all maxed out and everything my
wife decided to take the kids and move
in with her brother and decided to nd
what one wants to end the marriage so
now in was doing right now based on your
inability to earn them income or what
yeah I'm sure that was I think the straw
that broke the camel's back on that
whole situation mm-hmm but now I'm
basically here flat broke
really seriously in debt and and now I
you know I I'm an independent contractor
so every day I wake up and I'm trying to
get up and get motivated for work but
it's hard to do that in an empty house
and you know feeling let's just you know
living in solitude here so I'm just
wondering if you know because right now
I have somewhere in the area of like
$35,000 in credit card debt and my wife
probably has about 20 to 30 we owe
$15,000 in on a payment plan that were
paying in back taxes and we have two
cars that one that we owe five thousand
on and one that we owe $10,000
so this is the first month where I'm
thinking this is about I might not be
able to make these payments and and then
also trying to figure out what's the
financial cost going to be to actually
go through and get a divorce how long
ago did she move out about a week ago
how old are you 35 I'm sorry okay you
had a business failure now you've
attempted to launch this for six months
and it hasn't worked it's so far we
would classify it as a failure right and
now it's hitting your marriage okay
you've got to really stop and look at
this and say what I've been doing hasn't
been working we have to do something
different so if you could get a job
could you begin marriage counseling and
begin to work your way back out and
they'll put your marriage back together
like a job that pays money not not a lot
of commission job right yeah I would be
open to that I don't know it would be
mutual
I don't know if she would be or not but
yeah that would be something that would
be open to doing probably three months
late so doing that I don't blame her for
having tried the other gig but when it
gets to the point that she has given up
hope that her kids have a future with
your career choices it's time for you
make different career choices right yeah
yeah I'm not throwing cold water on you
I'm just trying to walk with you here
because you're in a real I mean you have
been through hell if you could take the
last year and bottle it you could sell
it as hot sauce that's true it's been I
spent off losing a business how how did
you say you are 35:35 yeah
losing a business and then being deeply
in debt and then the next thing you've
tried
do is failing is not working you're not
making money it's just you're just
getting punched all over I mean you got
both eyes black your nose is broke but
right now your lip you had the crap beat
out of you you know that is the truth
and so are you in a good church by
chance not really active you know you
have a good friend that say in their 40s
or 50s that you consider to have a
pretty good life that you think might
have a good faith walk yeah call that
guy today tell me I need to have coffee
with him you need some help he'll help
you whoever he is okay and he's gonna
lead you and he's gonna lead you in this
into a good spiritual community into
your church into his church and where
you can actually get a vibrant type of
real faith and and that pastor can help
you guys put your marriage back together
and this man can help mentor you and get
you back on a career path and then I'll
help you with the money part we can get
you out of debt but we need to get your
career moving and your marriage saved
first okay okay that's the most
important thing and we just you just had
the snot beat out of you man I mean I
was 28 I lost everything we we long I
mean we lost everything sure and I about
killed each other she tells people she
would have left but she didn't have a
car I mean we fought like hillbillies
because we are I mean we it was bad
brother and I felt about an inch tall
because everything I touched turned to
poop you know what I mean
and I felt like I felt like I was
worthless and that was 30 years ago and
but you know what got me out was I got
some guys around me I was in a good
church but my faith walk you know was it
just started and walking with God
walking with good men of character and
you know Sharon I spent time of marriage
counselor two or three different times
we've been married 37 years she says
we've had 30 good years of marriage
[Laughter]
you know you can you can turn all of
this around or there's this much poof
there has to be fertilizer right yeah
hey you hang on we'll get you into
Financial Peace University get you and
your wife in that you start working on a
career side and on the spiritual part
and I'll walk with you on the rest as
well